most of what we've talked about so far
has been atoms in isolation we have
thought about the number of electrons
and protons and neutrons and the
electron configuration of atoms but
atoms don't just operate in isolation if
that were the case the whole universe
including us would just be a bunch of
atoms drifting around what begins to be
interesting is how the atoms actually
interact with each other and one of the
most interesting forms of interaction is
when they stick to each other in some
way shape or form
and this sticking together of atoms is
what we are going to study in this video
another way to talk about it is how do
atoms bond
now as we will see there are several
types of bonds and it's really a
spectrum but let's just start with what
i would consider one of the more extreme
type of bonds and to understand it let's
get a periodic table of elements out
right over here
so let's say
that we are dealing with a group one
element let's say sodium right over here
what's interesting about group one
elements is that they have one valence
electron if we want to visualize the
valence electrons for say sodium we
could do it with what's known as a lewis
dot structure or a lewis electron dot
structure sometimes just called a dot
structure for short but because a
neutral sodium has one valence electron
we would just draw that one valence
electron
like that
now let's go to the other end of the
periodic table and say look at chlorine
chlorine is a halogen
halogens have seven valence electrons so
chlorine's valence electrons would look
like this
it has
one two three
four
five
six
seven valence electrons and so you can
imagine chlorine would love to get
another electron in order to complete
its outer shell and we've also studied
in other videos these atoms these
elements at the top right of the
periodic table which are not the noble
gases but especially the top of these
halogens things like oxygen nitrogen
these are very electronegative they like
to
pull electrons hog electrons and so what
do you think is going to happen when you
put these characters together
this guy wants to lose the electrons and
chlorine wants to gain an electron
well maybe the chlorine will take an
electron from the sodium now in a real
chemical reaction you would have
trillions of these and they're bouncing
around and different things are
happening but just for simplicity let's
just imagine that these are the only two
and let's imagine that this chlorine is
able to nab an electron from this sodium
so what is going to happen
well this sodium is then going to become
positively charged
because it's going to lose an electron
and then the chlorine
the chlorine is now going to gain an
electron so it's going to become a
chloride anion anion is a negative ion
it's a sodium cation a positive ion ion
means it's charged and now it's a
chloride anion so it has the valence
electrons that it had before and then
you could imagine that it gains one from
the sodium and now it has a negative
charge
now what do we know about positively
charged ions and negatively charged ions
well opposites attract coulomb forces so
these two characters are going to be
attracted to each other or another way
to think of it they're going to stick
together or another way you think about
it they are going to be bonded and they
will form a compound of sodium
chloride
and notice the whole compound here is
neutral it has a plus one charge for the
sodium a negative one charge for the
chloride but taken together it is
neutral because these are hanging out
together
and this type of bond between ions you
might guess what it's called
it is called an ionic bond
ionic
bond